estamos en la última sección del último
examen del s arte yo lo puedo creer por
fin logramos llegar a la recta final
estamos en la recta final y estamos en
el primer problema así que manos a la
obra primer problema problemas número
uno dice un restaurante tiene una lista
de menú con ocho platillos y tres
postres ok tengo ocho platillos ocho
platillos platillos y tengo tres postres
postres ok
cuántas combinaciones distintas de
platillo con postres se pueden dar bueno
pues la respuesta es muy sencilla se
pueden dar ocho por tres lo cual son 24
combinaciones combinaciones
combinaciones y bueno como se esto como
sé que tengo que multiplicar 8 por 3
porque podemos poner aquí los 8
platillos y cada uno de los platillos se
puede servir con tres postres distintos
con este con éste y con este este con
este estrellas etcétera etcétera por lo
tanto hay 24 combinaciones distintas
para ofrecer aquí en este restaurante
muy bien problema número uno fácil vamos
ser el problema número dos problema
número dos que dice la suma de 3x y 5 es
igual al producto de un tercio con x la
suma de 3x y 5 3 x 5 me estoy tomando
los maestros 2 esto debe ser igual al
producto a la multiplicación de un
tercio con x de un tercio con x
cuál de los siguientes 100 62 muestran
la relación mencionada en el problema
bueno pues la relación mencionada en el
problema justo está 13 x + 5 es igual a
un tercio de equis y en mis incisos es
el inciso e insisto me dice justo esto 3
x + 5 es igual a un tercio de x o 3 x 5
es igual a x por un tercio es
exactamente lo mismo vamos a hacer el
problema número 3 a dice un empleado
accidentalmente arrojó un documento
importante en uno de los 90 botes de
basura que tiene la empresa wow
algún documento importante en uno de los
botes de basura yo creo que lo van a
despedir pobre empleado espero que no lo
despidan dice ah fue accidentalmente el
problema es que no se acuerda en cuál de
los botes lo arrojó la posibilidad de
que esté en uno de estos botes de basura
es la misma para cada bote ok esto me
suena que va a ser un problema de
probabilidad si hay exactamente 15
es azul es cuál es la probabilidad de
que este documento esté en un bote de
basura de ese color
bueno pues recuerda que la probabilidad
son casos posibles entre casos totales y
solamente tengo 15 botes de color azul
entonces 15 botes de estos son de color
azul mientras que tengo 90 botes totales
por lo tanto casos factibles gastos
posibles son 15 15 de color azul entre
casos totales que son 90 los botes de
basura y bueno 90 entre 15 es lo mismo
que podemos sacar quinta arriba es más
podemos dividir entre 15 arriba y 15
abajo y me va a quedar a 1 entre 90
entre 15 es 6 15 30 45 60 75 90 ok a 6
un 6º la probabilidad es un sexto de que
se encuentra en un bote de color azul y
ya está el problema número 3 así que
vamos a hacer
a siguiente problema el problema número
4 que yo espero que me quepa aquí el
problema número 4 cuantos distintos
pares de enteros satisfacen la ecuación
x entre james esto es igual a un medio
bueno pues esta ecuación de aquí la
podemos ver de una manera mucho más
sencilla si cruzamos a esta esta
división para acá la voy a pasar para
que va multiplicando y ésta lo voy a
pasar para acá
multiplicando es decir voy a multiplicar
a ambos lados toda esta ecuación a por 2
10 por 2 y entonces voy a obtener a 2
james x x / y me queda 2 x 2 x esto es
igual a 2 por un medio es lo mismo que
ella y es igual a 2x y para cuántos
pares de enteros se cumple esta ecuación
de aquí bueno pues para un buen porque
si yo barrio x
entonces me puede dar un valor para ello
duplicando este valor en x pero x puede
tomar cualquier valor entero por ejemplo
a que x valga 1 y lleva al ga 2
bien por ejemplo que x valga 2 y 4 3 y 6
a 4 y 8 5 y 10 y así no puedo pasar
horas y horas poniendo enteros en equis
y obteniendo otro entero en yen porque
es el doble de ese mismo entero
entonces tengo una infinidad infinidad
de respuestas tengo muchas respuestas
por lo tanto vamos a ver los incisos e
insisto él dice que son más de cuatro y
escucha mi respuesta fíjate bien aquí
tengo a de hecho más de cuatro en menos
de diez segundos de ti más de cuatro por
lo tanto a la respuesta es el insisto en
el inciso que me dice que son más de
cuatro es decir tenemos una infinidad de
respuestas para esta ecuación que tengo
aquí tengo una infinidad de distintos
pares de enteros que satisfagan esta
ecuación bueno problema número cuatro ya
no me cabe aquí el problema número cinco
así que vamos a hacerlo por acá problema
número cinco dice hoy tengo una gráfica
vamos a ver qué dice el problema de
acuerdo a la gráfica siguiente durante
cuáles de los siguientes periodos de dos
meses periodos de dos meses
la librería l vendió la menor cantidad
de libros periodos de dos meses ok vamos
en la gráfica
tengo algo así más o menos así ok y
tengo algunos meses
aquí tengo junio aquí o no dejen que me
dé herramienta aquí tengo a junio junio
aquí tengo a julio a julio aquí tengo a
enero febrero marzo abril mayo junio
julio agosto aquí tengo agosto aquí
tengo a septiembre aquí tengo septiembre
aquí tengo a octubre y por acá tengo a
noviembre y desde el lado tengo a la
cantidad de libros vendidos aquí tengo a
10 a 20
a 30 y a 40 de lujo y vamos a poner las
gráficas que tengo aquí tengo que en
junio se vendieron menos de 10 algo más
o menos como por aquí se vendieron un
poquito menos de 10 así en julio en
julio se vendieron a se vendieron 40 se
vendieron un buen se vendieron como 40
libros ok por otra parte tengo agosto en
agosto se vendieron como 10 parece que
si es 10 aquí es casi exacto 10 en
septiembre en septiembre se vendieron a
como 30 y algo 30
y lo voy a poner como por aquí 30 y algo
en octubre en octubre se vendieron a
menos de 30 como la mitad entre 30 y 20
por aquí y en noviembre en noviembre
para finalizar voy a cambiar de color se
vendieron como 30 parece muy cercano al
valor de 30 ok y me dice que me tomes 2
meses
por parejas por periodos de dos meses
entonces qué me dice el inciso a el
éxito o no
déjame cambiar de herramienta el inciso
am me dice junio y julio junio y julio
ok es decir me fui a fijar en estos dos
de aquí en junio julio y bueno lo que se
me ocurre es que pongamos cierta
cantidad de libros al azar a ver por
aquí son como siete y aquí son como 40
entonces junio-julio sumarían 47 aquí
tendría 47 libros vendidos ok vamos a
ver los demás
inciso b
julio julio y agosto
es decir estos dos de acá y aquí tengo
como 40 y aquí tengo como 10 son como 50
libros 50 libros vendidos a ver
abc vamos a fijarnos en el sem que es
agosto y septiembre es decir estos
destacan aquí tengo 10 y aquí tengo como
30 y como 33 más o menos entonces estos
dos suman 43 hasta ahorita este es mi
candidato para hacer el periodo de dos
meses en que la librería l medio me en
la menor cantidad de libros este parece
ser a bs de de a que es septiembre y
octubre septiembre de octubre es decir
estos dos tengo 33 más algo más que 10
aquí va a ser algo más que a 43 y creo
que es como 25 a la suma de esto es 58
es decir es algo más grande que en el
valor más bajo que está ahorita
encontrado a veces de m
y en octubre y noviembre y si te das
cuenta también según más grande que 43
aquí tengo 25 y aquí tengo como 30 a 55
y bueno este no es el periodo donde se
vendieron la menor cantidad de libros el
periodo en donde se vendieron la menor
cantidad de libros es agosto y
septiembre es esta de aquí esta es mi
respuesta agosto septiembre porque se
vendieron 43 libros y aunque lo estamos
haciendo más o menos al tanteo quiero
que te des cuenta que las cantidades no
varían mucho por lo tanto si puedo
concluir que agosto y septiembre es la
menor cantidad y se vendieron la menor
cantidad de libros posibles problema
número 5 ok
un problema número 6 vamos el problema
número 6 que dice tenemos una recta
tenemos una recta más o menos así como
esta y por aquí tengo a vamos a ver a
este de aquí porque aquí tengo el punto
por aquí tengo el punto b y por aquí
tengo el punto c del ojo en la figura
siguiente hace es igual a 24 hace es
igual a 24 la distancia que hay de aquí
hasta acá son 24 unidades ok y por otra
parte me dicen
que ave es igual a a ser ave esta
distancia es igual a esta instancia es
decir b es el punto medio entre hice y
por lo tanto de aquí acá hay dos
unidades y de aquí acá hay 12 unidades
dice el punto d el cual no se muestra en
la recta ok no tenemos aquí a de cumple
que ade es igual a ver a d es igual a a
be ok el punto de está en la recta y si
está en la recta a debe estar por aquí
pero cumple que ade es igual a ave
vd esto es igual de de ok tiene que
estar a la mitad entre de even es igual
es el punto medio entre d y b así que
está justo por aquí de tal manera que la
instancia quede aquí acá son 6 este es
de la distancia que hay de que acá es 6
porque recuerda que la distancia total
de a ave son 12 unidades y entonces como
d es el punto medium lo que me está
diciendo aquí es que es un punto que
vive en esta recta y que cumple que la
distancia entre este punto y ya es la
misma que entre este punto y ver
entonces a esta distancia debe ser 6 y
esta debe de ser 6 y lo que me preguntan
justo es cuánto vale de c de ese es lo
que yo quiero saber ahora para eso date
cuenta que esa distancia de aquí hasta
acá
esta es la distancia que yo quiero saber
y bueno esto es a esta distancia de aquí
esta vez lo cual son 6 unidades y
después de ver hasta cm
esta distancia de que hasta acá lo cual
son 12 unidades por lo tanto tengo 10
unidades de c es decir ok otro problema
más que no estaba nada difícil así que
vamos el problema número 7 para terminar
este vídeo creo que si me da tiempo de
hacer el problema número 7 que dice a
qué expresión es equivalente 6 x 10
elevado a la menos n más a 1 x 10 será
menos n por 10 la menos n
si n es un entero positivo aquí es
equivalente esta expresión bueno pues
aquí tengo 6 veces 10 elevado a la menos
n y aquí tengo una vez más 10 elevado a
la menos seno si aquí factorizar el 10
elevado a la menos n tendría 10 elevado
a la menos nm que multiplica primero a 6
y después a 1 está de acuerdo es decir
que esto x - m es decir que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 7 por 10
elevado a la
en esto de aquí debería hacer mi
respuesta e inclusive tú lo puedes
visualizar así aquí tengo 6 veces 10
elevado a la menos m así que lo voy a
poner justo por acá abajo tengo a 10
elevado a la menos en más 10 elevado a
la menos n más 10 elevado a la menos en
10 elevado de - n más 10 el balón a
menos n 123 45 más 10 el balón a menos
tienen
aquí tengo 6 veces 10 elevado a la menos
n aunque creo que esta no es la mejor
forma de que lo hagas el examen pero
bueno al menos lo puedes visualizar si
aquí tengo una vez más 10 elevado a
menos tiene a esto lo voy a sumar 10
elevado de al menos n y bueno pues esto
es 7 veces 7 veces 10 elevado a la menos
n 7 x 10 - r y si nos fijamos en los
incisos no están mis incisos
bueno pero es que esto esto lo podemos
escribir de la siguiente manera 7 por 10
al menos n es exactamente lo mismo que 7
por y aquí tengo una potencia negativa
entonces la voy a pasar para abajo me lo
quedan 7 por 1 entre 10 elevado a la n o
lo que es lo mismo hace una
multiplicación de quebrados me queda 7
entre 10 elevado a la n iv está así
están mis respuestas es mi inciso b lo
único que hice fue utilizar una regla de
los exponentes que me dice que si
tenemos ha elevado a la menos b esto es
lo mismo que uno entre ha elevado a la
vez con la potencia diapositiva ok
inciso b y ya no tengo tiempo para hacer
un siguiente problema así que en el
siguiente vídeo seguimos este último
examen y esta última sección